what is the tea honeybee it's me can you
Muse and the beauty Nisha Lopez
Alexis Michelle oh wow it's me Jimbo hi
I'm James Mansfield hi I'm Monica
Beverly Hills and I'm Miss Darien Lake
I'm hiding closet from the Disney
Channel I'm Mrs Kasha Davis married Lady
it's your favorite homegirl lalari and
we are the cast of RuPaul's records
All-Stars season eight here playing
who's who's with BuzzFeed honey
[Music]
[Laughter]
we all know she's a real villain here I
just think that I'm more beautiful and I
think that you think that too
I agree
a pen of course backhanded
thank you
anymore
[Laughter]
oh
um
[Laughter]
James
again
wow the true feelings come out that's
pretty vintage that's part of your game
the mega lots of the Pepsi you
she might be in the other room yeah
it's you it's you it is yeah it is
[Laughter]
ever
[Music]
all right
well I took half of the Anastasia myself
[Music]
[Laughter]
she's usually just sitting there doing
this just staring I think yeah
Michelle loved you I think she loved me
and I love her she loved this Jessica I
was ready for her to be rude with me
when she was nice I'm fine yes
[Music]
who's better watch
everything she does yeah like the
emotion that she brings yeah
oh definitely me
you guys put a point at me right
I think everyone here is a really good
lipsticker but me
I'm gonna say everyone here except
oh
my God
[Music]
oh
candy Muse
I'm a pleaser I like to try to make
everybody happy is that what we're
calling it
Nation Nation
[Laughter]
because Heidi would laugh on it she will
break
myself
you have to think you're the funniest
girl in the room right it is
yeah yeah um
[Laughter]
yummy
[Music]
yeah
stunner face
get into it there you go how about this
jump scare I'm trying to think yeah
still in drag Prince color I love a
stone I love to shine in and out of drag
so yeah she was more masculine and
dragon
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
I think oh maybe because I helped what
the hell yeah that's why I think Jessica
who me yeah
everyone's ready for the runway and Jim
will still putting our Mingo it takes a
village it takes a village yeah 20 hours
crease and like literally another day
oh I did it today
she rolled out about nine
o'clocked yes yes I'll give it to me and
she's modest yeah
I think you me you're a fun maybe
hopefully
I say Jimbo Jimbo is just like stupid to
look at so
yeah
the challenge and having that day
and make sure you tune in every single
Friday to watch RuPaul's Drag Race All
Stars eight streaming only on Prima Plus
[Laughter]
I know
foreign
[Music]